now certain plants have the capacity to
cause
cancer cells to commit suicide it's very
interesting
so you may have heard of sulfurophane
which is a phytonutrient
that's in broccoli sprouts broccoli
cauliflower
kale brussels sprouts cabbage bok choy
and other cruciferous vegetables and
even john hopkins university
attempted to get the patents on broccoli
sprouts
because they did the studies on
sulforaphane finding that it's
anti-cancer
so the question is if these
phytonutrients like sulforaphane
have the ability to cause cancer cells
to commit suicide
do they do the same thing with our cells
okay well i'm going to show you a
specific section
of the study that talks about this
concept
so this is a quote taken from the study
i'm going to put it down below
okay sulforaphane selectively
inhibited hgac activity
and what is that well htac activity is
really just an
enzyme that affects the dna stability
causing the dna to be very unstable in a
cell
okay and induced which means triggered
p21 expression now what that does p21
expression mean
that means apoptosis this
this is the term that describes a cell
committing suicide
okay so sulforaphane inhibits this
enzyme
that normally keeps the dna stable so
now this dna
becomes unstable and triggers
the cell to commit suicide
okay in benign hyperplasia what is that
tumors okay and
cancer cells while it only cause
a transient which is kind of a not a
long-term thing it's a short-term
type thing decrease in hdac
activity and did not affect
the p21 expression in normal cells and
this is why they said
selectively okay so you're not going to
have to worry about getting
cancer from eating these plants because
it's selective it has the ability to
differentiate
and go after the cancer cells and leave
your cells
alone and so the question is why did a
plant even come up with this chemical in
the first place well
plants have enemies bacteria insects
that type of thing so that's the defense
mechanism and so it's pretty safe for
our bodies unless you have some
gut damage where there's leaky gut for
example but if you don't have gut
issues i would highly recommend having
some of these foods on a regular basis
as they have a huge benefit of
selectively causing the cancer cell to
commit suicide
hey before you go real quick i have a
course entitled
how to bulletproof your immune system
it's a free course
i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself
and so you can tolerate and resist your
environment much better
by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description
right down below
check it out and get signed up today